well Bud Light has become the poster boy
for brand mismanagement from multiple
perspectives so let me let me lay it out
for you because these the discussions
that have risen and the narrative that's
risen around Bud Light is probably a
good lesson for every CEO in every
sector of the economy number one it
highlights the power of social media
this this issue went viral in 48 hours
yeah and most often when an issue goes
viral like that it burns out in another
48 hours but that's not what happened
here the story and narrative change to
sales and so people that did not like
the message regardless of where you
stand on these social issues or gender
narrative or whatever
they took it out by basically boycotting
the product immediately yeah and
switching preference to other brands
that did not make them get involved in
this issue and other viral videos go on
on social media like Kid Rock shooting
Bud Light cans and people dumping Bud
Light and all and so that just adds to
it right well it's because that
narrative became very powerful and
people piled on now if you're trying to
manage that and trying to learn
something from it and I certainly talked
to all my CEOs about this because
here we are talking about it in its
second month yeah this is a nightmare
from hell for the brand and the sales
don't they haven't
some brands in the Anheuser-Busch have
have had declines get lesser but Bud
light's still down big this is worse
than New Coke old Coke and it's becoming
its own story for the ages I'll be
teaching this one at Harvard there's no
question about it because you have to
ask yourself in crisis management what
do you do because if you go to the other
side and try and balance the gender
narrative you're going to get a whole
new onslaught of people yeah that don't
like that and there have been bars that
have banned all Anheuser-Busch products
because Bud Light tried to distance
itself from Dylan Mulvaney and what
happened so the lesson learned and what
everybody should think about in every
consumer product category
when you take polarized positions on any
narrative you are going to alienate 50
of your consumer 100 of the time so if
you're willing to do something very
controversial because you think it's
going to go viral in a positive way you
need to analyze the downside in a
negative way as well
in consumer goods and services
Republicans drink beer Democrats drink
beer some believe in the gender
neutrality some don't but they all
consume your product so if you know that
with certainty and you have billions of
dollars of capitalization at stake why
would you go down that road in the first
place and so if I were a board member
there saying
show me who's responsible for this
because at the end of the day when you
go into new territory consumer goods or
services like changing the flavor as
Coke found out decades ago yeah
you need to own that as the CEO if
you're the man or woman running this
thing you need to own it 100 because you
can't blame it on a brand manager you
can't blame it on an advertising agency
you own it and so now what's happened
within Corporate America and I can
assure you this has been a conversation
every boardroom is who's running brand
here who's deciding what networks we
post on who is actually doing our social
media who is actually calling the shots
on the content because never before has
the control of content after those
frames leave and get posted you don't
have control of it anymore the rest of
the world decides what they want to do
with it and you've given plenty of
examples of how it gets reposted and
used to promote other people's
narratives yeah and so that brand got
decimated and at the end of the day I'm
sorry to say this but the CEO
it's their fault
so what okay let's say I'm Bud Light I'm
on Shark Tank I need money and and you
get I give you uh Mr Wonderful give us
20 I'll give you a 20 stake help us what
would you do how would you fix this can
you fix this well as in you know I look
at the decimation of the brand within a
portfolio of Brands I mean Bud Light
used to be the go-to college beer the
Colorado pure water story all that stuff
it got decimated here it it's no longer
that beer it's a beer with a a sordid
past and so you have to think about what
do you do with that how do you
creatively dig yourself out of that hole
how do you re-establish that brand and
I'm not sure there's a clear path right
now everybody involved in that brand is
begging for the media to stop and here
you are with me talking about it again
months later yeah and and it's not the
only conversation I've had and so when I
now talk about branding and managing
Brands and I teach young cohorts mostly
graduating Engineers which is where I
focus this is the case this is the one
that you're actually living today and so
for me what what I would if I had to try
and you know think about how would you
manage out of this hole
first step is stabilization
first step is to stabilize the decline
stop it from declining that's not easy
to do though no it's not but you can't
think about gaining share yet you just
have to stop the narrative and cauterize
the wound and then go from there
you know there's lots of metrics and we
do this in our own businesses you can
actually monitor by the hour on every
platform what is occurring okay and so
you have to find if I were doing this I
would have that analysis in front of me
saying where are the green shoots in
this story where are we getting some
support where are our users talking
about their you know their childhood
growing up with Bud Light you know Bud
Light as a as a favorable choice on a
caloric basis on a nutritional basis
whatever it is where are the green
shoots where do we spend there because
Bud Light is a light beer there is
demand for light beers particularly
amongst beer drinking men over 40. I
mean you got to go there and find those
green shoots and you know clearly
when you're in crisis mode and the heads
are going to roll it's just too much
capitalized loss it's just too much
influencers are part of the deal now
right Brands need influencers they use
them on all different ways Tick Tock or
whatever
but you're using people you don't know
exactly what they're gonna do right you
you hope they do something good for you
but
it's a danger isn't it it is
so
I have a pretty big advisory business
and I work with a lot of financial
services companies insurance companies
tax companies where they hire me to be a
paid spokesperson so let me give you my
perspective of my role in these
first of all
never be a spokesperson for a brand you
don't actually consume or use that you
don't personally use
because that's the only way you'll
understand the DNA of the brand so
companies need to know when they're
hiring influencer they're hiring a user
yeah
prove to me that you use my product you
know when I think about companies like
start engine that do Equity crowdfunding
I'm just naming off some of my paid
spokesperson's role I meant not only in
my paid spokesperson I'm an investor in
the company because I use the platform I
think about Wonder trust which is
employee retention credit program
I use that platform for all of my
companies to go get there credits
because right now Banks aren't lending
so we get up to 26 000 per employee and
I'm all over the networks now promoting
wondertrust.com if you don't have your
ERC that's where you go to get it I
think about tax Hive Financial Services
we're talking about here I use all of
these products in my portfolio or
personally
so that's number one when you're hiring
a a paid spokesperson
why and how do they know your brand do
they use it number one number two are
they able to read the room in other
words I understand the consumer
of the you know employee retention
credit it's a small business owner with
five to Five Hundred employees
I know who they are there's millions of
them in America I know what matters to
them I make sure I don't go down some
narrative that's irrelevant to my
constituency so when you go into gender
narrative on a beer which is primarily
consumed by men maybe you should have
thought a little bit about that in
reading that room maybe you should say
well does this really fit my consumer's
psyche and narrative this is important
and then lastly do you understand the
responsibility you have as a paid
spokesperson you are basically being
trusted by the board of that company to
help them expand their business and
reduce their customer acquisition costs
you own that at six in the morning when
you wake up and at 11 o'clock at night
when you go to bed how have you modified
your life to be responsible you can't
get in a car and do something crazy you
can can't expect to do something off
brand in the night or you know out in
the evening and not think that that's
not going to get back to you you are now
effectively being watched 24 7 because
they're spending millions of dollars
putting you on television on social
media and talking about you and you have
to live your life according to that
metric and that was the thing that I
realized so much when I got into this
business is how it forced me to change
the way I lived you know I love wine I
have a wine business I sell hundreds of
thousands of cases
a year but you can't drink too much of
it I can't drink too much of it and I
can never drink it and get in a car ever
again not that I'm admitting I ever did
but that's something I can't take drugs
I can't you know not that I want to but
it made me realize
if I'm going to take this role and this
responsibility and you know who told me
this my 29 year old daughter really yeah
she said you know Dad the one thing that
that you don't understand is
you're so scrutinized now I see you
everywhere yeah
one bad move
and you're canceled everybody recognizes
you pretty much right I mean she used
the word it'll be canceled and I said
what are you talking about she said I'm
not kidding just look at these feeds
look at how many hundreds of thousands
of comments there are in this stuff good
bad and ugly
and they're watching you 24 7. the
company will cut you right away yeah and
so for me and then as as time passes and
I've been doing this for years now if
you can gain the trust of a board of
directors of a company that's in
financial services more come knocking
but I've already modified my life in the
way I I work for the first deal
I have no choice I don't know if I'm
ever going to be the wild Mr Wonderful I
used to be I just don't think I'm going
to get to do that but maybe I'm older
anyways a little less fun but more money
well yes but I I don't
you know it's a great question when
you're asking me because people say do
that do you do that for money no no I
really enjoy the work I really enjoy
what I do and I love the challenge of
gaining market share and reducing
customer acquisition costs for all of my
companies I invest in and when people
approach me and say oh we want you to be
a paid spokesperson for our company I
say
I don't own your company I don't own any
of your company I'm not doing it unless
I own a piece of the company so that I'm
in the shareholders shoes and I
understand their Journey so like that
exactly like Shark Tank you're you're
always buying in and so I'm I'm actually
investing in their company and they're
paying me be a paid spokesperson because
I believe in their mandate and their
mission and and I think that in my view
that keeps you young I I really enjoy
this work all right lastly you talk
about the financial services
how is the economy in your view it's
getting more difficult right now for
companies to get investment right to get
money to be able to to get capital
it is and and I'll tell you why in a
nutshell everything changed a few weeks
ago in the collapse of Silicon Valley
Bank First Republic and signature
all of a sudden all the regional Banks
the 4 500 of them are are not lending
anymore uh as we speak Congress is
debating this the members are talking
about it there's hearings about the
collapse of Silicon Valley Bank Hagerty
put out a bill the deposit bill I met
with him in Washington yesterday and his
staff he's got a solution that simply
says okay for the next 24 months
any bank account in a regional bank will
guarantee it up to a hundred million
dollars if it Bears no interest now
who's going to put money in an account
with no interest only payroll on
Wednesdays so he's trying to protect
payroll in Regional banks that makes
sense to me but it's not an imputed
guarantee for everything and so that's
not going to stop the consolidation of
small Banks we have 4 500 now I bet you
within three years four years there'll
only be 800 left they're going to have
to get together that's what happened in
England that's what happened in Canada
that's what happened in Australia that's
what happened Switzerland Europe France
Germany all of these places much fewer
banks with imputed guarantees that's
where we're going Mr Wonderful you can
see him of course as always on Shark
Tank and also he's chairman of O'Leary
Ventures Kevin O'Leary thank you so much
for being with us you got it thank you